I've told you in the past that I take
your comments seriously well now I'm
putting my money where my mouth is and
watching an episode that you asked me to
watch here we go house m.d. episode
three stories three guys walk into a
clinic their legs hurt the less than two
hours one of these three will be tossed
out of the hospital because they were
faking it to score narcotics and one
will be very close to death where is the
pain localized it started just above my
ankle and it's radiating up so what
should we do first
family history indicative of leg pain
that's a very short list any history of
bone cancer
osteogenesis imperfecta or multiple
myeloma it could be a blood issue we
should run a CBC and a d-dimer and get
an MRI MRI or a PET scan they're asking
him questions really out of order in
medical school you're taught to go with
the o pqrst model o being on set P being
provocative palliative cubing the
quality of the pain our radiation of the
pain s as the severity of the pain and T
timing which could mean like time of day
or if they've ever had this issue in the
past
you don't just randomly start asking
family history out of nowhere because if
you start asking that it could lead you
down a line of questioning where you're
gonna spend a lot of time and not get
any valuable info you want the
high-yield stuff up front sorry
thanks for playing patients dead you
killed him we had no time to run any
tests there's nothing we could do you
had time to look at the leg puncture
snakebite that would be my guess so a
lot of times when you have an open wound
like this farmers presenting with you
have to think obviously about bug bites
animal bites that sort of thing because
we're in the northeast coast we always
jump to Lyme disease
too much pain to be a slipped disc could
be herniated and appending the nerve
root or it could be referred pain from
his groin sir are you getting pain
cooling it's not the back sir where are
you getting out hey he's not gonna tell
us anything if we don't get him out of
pain give him 50 milligrams of Demerol
we have no history he could be allergic
what do I do we can't diagnose a lot of
screams better than killing him with
painkillers that there's ways you can
distinguish whether someone's actually
in pain or not if someone's in
horrendous pain their heart rates gonna
go up you can't fake that you can't make
your heart rate go up while you're
faking pain
second of all you can when you're doing
your physical exam there's ways to test
if someone's really having pain I do
this all the time in the hospital I'll
put pressure on the area while the
patient is looking at me and I'll ask if
it hurts if they're screaming in pain
I'll change the subject or I'll ask them
about something else is going on but
leave my hand on the area where they're
still having pain and while I'm talking
to them I'll gently start increasing
pressure on that area they're not
jumping in pain it's either as not as
bad as they say it is or they may be
pain seeking exhibiting pain seeking
behavior this example doesn't look like
a person's faking pain you did exactly
what his attending did and that was the
proper way to handle the case yeah the
guy used him as a dealer you're gonna
see a lot of drug seeking behavior in
your practice and there's a reason it
works sister making you feel better
really fast
action paddles and epi the reason you
give the epi is not because it's hard to
about to stop is because his Airways
closing from having an anaphylactic
attack to what looks like the snake
anti-venom so you need to give
epinephrine immediately usually to the
upper thigh or some other muscular
region where you can get well absorbs
very quickly let's say we take five
get some coffee go pee it's funny like
he's fine with the medical students
going out to do that nowadays all the
medical students would be buried in
their phones trying to Google what the
answer is or Google what the
possibilities are what a good doctor
means and medicine has changed from
those who know the most to those who can
get the best information in the most
efficient way possible because there's
so much information it's being updated
so quickly it's almost impossible to be
up-to-date on every single study on
every single subject I've heard that
there was five studies coming out per
minute in the scientific field so it's
impossible to stay up-to-date with every
piece of literature but if you're very
good with internet research you're very
good with verifying sources you're very
good at reading journal articles and
understanding which one's the quality of
one versus not you can make a good
decision and possibly the best decision
for your patient from being able to
research oh the patient responded to
epinephrine and the allergic reaction
was arrested unfortunately the patient
continues to deteriorate maybe the snake
Wrangler was wrong about the topic or
the faxes of venom tests have confirmed
it's a timber rattlesnake
no it's not notice the volume I skimmed
over that and the gender and the
colorings I'm right - the name of this
name - hundred milligrams our guy got
bit less than four hours ago
there's no way snake regenerates that
much about it that quickly we're
supposed to know how fast makes make the
venom nope
plus you got a patient bit like one okay
that was just ridiculous I mean I get I
get that House has to know a lot but he
doesn't know how fast snakes regenerate
their venom that's just insane I don't I
guess now I know that - but where does
he get that
snake's venom regeneration it hurts
again he came back on average drug
addicts are stupid we're gonna put this
hard rubber tube up your urethra and
into your bladder may be a little
uncomfortable by beginning of some sort
of anesthetic we're concerned about
allergic reactions today the guy can
handle a rod in his penis for a half an
hour he's really sick okay
you don't just put a catheter in because
you want to see how serious someone is
about getting medications there are ways
to check for people who are malingering
malingering is basically when a person
is trying to act sick in order to to get
some sort of secondary game like drugs
like a day off work like disability
these things do happen and you need to
consider them not first and foremost in
your mind but they new do need to be in
your thought process in your
differential wrong snake tried every
other antivenom we had or too late yep
he's dying you're dying in a few hours
there's nothing we can do except deal
with the pain well I need to go home
you're not going on
my dog what will happen to my dog
neighbors don't like him so the Humane
Society take man to find him oh no they
won't
yeah but maybe maybe my hand it wasn't a
snake bite was it I assumed that Cujo
bit one of your neighbors a while back
you tell me that he bit you and I got a
recording
cujo's gonna record he gets the chair I
don't know if that's how it works
the good news is you might just live the
bad news is your Doc's gonna die
residents don't go to people's homes and
steal the dogs and swab the mouth this
just doesn't happen they would call the
local dog catcher I don't know the
someone from the Humane Society to come
and get the dog
bring it in test the mouth and then
they'll deliver them the results
residents don't do this because then
their employment insurance would be
through the roof because they're always
undergoing these crazy risks and B to
nuts would you call that ball of yarn
what color is your opinion
yellow causes your blood rad-foot toys
did I use red yellow and brown and brown
what causes brown waste means the
kidneys are shutting down
why trauma and that his history would
indicate what are you missing muscle
death
rhabdomyolysis not your case nothing
wrong with the consult dying muscle
leaks myoglobin it's toxic to the
kidneys medical students were saying
that it was trauma or damaged they just
weren't saying it the right way so he's
being really mean to them I don't
condone this kind of pimping dog smells
are pretty filthy but they have natural
antibodies to fight off missing stuff we
don't
that's why dog guys can be so nasty he's
right dog bites can be nasty but
actually human bites are worse if you
look at the infection rate from an
untreated human bite versus a dog bite
human bites are actually more likely to
get infected and that's because human
mouths have a much greater range of
bacteria and viruses that live in our
human mouths as compared to dogs we may
need to remove the leg I still don't
know what this gentleman's problem is he
has a muscle damage from life I don't I
don't not follow it and what did the MRI
show his MRI showed that the leg pain
was caused by the self-injection wasn't
caused by an infection
the compartments in Germany was an
aneurysm that clotted leading to an
infarction
right house we have to do the surgery
now I get why you guys recommended this
episode I was wondering what happened to
house it's like unless this is a whole
thing as a forest it would probably take
a few days to diagnose it because it's
such a unique and rare condition that it
wouldn't appear at the top of your list
if you're thinking of aneurysm at the
top of your list you're gonna be doing a
lot of unnecessary MRIs and missing a
lot of problems that are much more
common so you need to think horses not
zebras but I know since this house MD
zebras are usually the first thing they
talk about do a bypass restore the
circulation amputation is safer for you
or me the blockage of blood for date
blockage yes it caused muscle cell death
and those cells die they release
cytokines and potassium to restore the
blood flow instead of just lopping it
all off then all that crap gets washed
back into my system his cytokines cause
organ failure and the potassium could
cause cardiac arrest on the other hand
can we just get the use of my life back
this is really interesting so whenever
you have a part of the body that doesn't
have blood going through it for a very
long period of time that body the part
of the body dies becomes necrotic that's
medical term for it because of ischemia
lack of oxygen it dies because blood is
bringing oxygen to those areas when a
muscle dies for example it releases
these inflammatory cells called
cytokines it also releases potassium
because when a cell ruptures the first
thing that releases are the most
important thing that it releases is
potassium and having too high of a
potassium in your bloodstream is very
dangerous it can be lethal and having
too much of inflammatory cells can also
be lethal and cause organ damage so you
have that problem going on because his
muscles have been without blood for a
long period of time in his leg but then
as you restore blood flow you have
reperfusion of that area you can also
get even more inflammation going and
inflammatory markers going because he's
bringing healthy blood into damaged
blood and that sparks to even more
inflammation and that's why dr. Cuddy's
actually encouraging him to go for the
amputation to leave all those cytokines
and inflammatory cells and potassium
in the leg and not cause even more
inflammation than pain but I also
understand what he's coming from where
he doesn't want to lose his leg it's
risky what he's saying it's not
advisable what he's saying and I could
see a lot of Surgeons turning down this
procedure because they don't see that
this is ideal for him as a doctor you
always want to do what's best for the
patient and let the patient decide
what's best for their bodies but if
they're telling you to do a procedure
that you think is very risky and
unnecessary you're well within your
means to try and convince them otherwise
if you were right the pain would be
subsiding you'd be getting better
no it's not we've got to let them cut
the leg off it's my leg it's my life the
middle ground you were talking about we
go in to have the dead muscle there's
still some risk of reperfusion injury
but give me the forms you need signed
[Music]
if our house I'd be pretty mad about
that but then again this is why the
bioethics committee comes into play
because you're technically doing
something the patient doesn't want and
it's explicitly said he doesn't want but
you know it's better for them it's such
a thin line I'm not sure what the right
call here is but as Medical proxy she
does have say over what happens to his
body right now because of the extent the
muscle removed utility of the patient's
leg was severely compromised because of
the time delay in making the diagnosis
patient continues to experience chronic
pain a lot of people don't realize this
but when you're on chronic opioid
medications which is just essentially
it's a masking agent for the pain it's
not treating your page just hiding the
pain when you're on that for a long
period of time it changes the chemistry
of your brain and actually makes you
feel something known as hyperalgesia
where you feel more pain and are more
sensitive to pain so that sometimes in a
patient who has chronic pain you have to
reduce the amount of pain medications
they take for them over time to feel
less pain it's a paradoxical complicated
concept but I've actually had a patient
that he's 81 years old thirty years of
back pain he's been on opiate
medications for two years he's taken
morphine and when he came to me says dr.
Marshall Skye you're my last hope and
when I talked to him about it I said
that I know this is gonna sound crazy
but I have to lower your dose and
eventually get you off of your narcotic
medications if you want to improve this
pain and actually right now we're at a
point where he's not taking any narcotic
medications for his pain he's going to
the gym he's golfing he's felt better
than ever
narcotics aren't always the right answer
they have a place there's definitely a
role for them but they're not always the
right answer they definitely have harms
and sometimes those harms outweigh the
benefits that we need not lie about that
she had no right to do that
she had the proxy she knew he didn't
want to
she saved his life we don't know that
maybe you would have been fine
doesn't matter it's the patients call
the patient's an idiot
little do they know you usually are
[Music]
it wasn't clear to me in the episode if
they understand that it's him because
they were still talking smack at the end
of that of the episode I do think that
sometimes he crosses the line is a
little rude but that's dr. house he's
just got this personality that's like
angry and wants everyone to see him as
the bad guy when in reality he wants to
do the right thing and he wants to help
people but he comes off harsh at times I
feel like whenever he says a patient is
dumb or doesn't do the right thing he's
essentially thinking that because he's
thinking about the mistake he made of
not amputating his leg and going through
all those surgeries and procedures and
having this chronic pain issue what if
he just would have gotten an amputation
got a replacement you know there's so
many ways to get a prosthetic nowadays
if you have another episode in the later
seasons season two may be season 3 drop
it down below in the comments I'll watch
that episode I want to watch more of
this series
I like watching house it refreshes a lot
of my knowledge that I I know I studied
back in the day but I haven't really
utilized this is a great way for me to
learn and for you guys to learn at home
so keep those comments coming subscribe
if you like my content and most
importantly as always stay happy and
healthy
[Music]